you know how when you're watching a
magician perform a trick he very often
will make an elaborate show of something
with one hand in order to distract you
so he can pull the trick with the other
hand while you're not watching you know
that
politicians use the same technique so
right now we're all supposed to be
talking about the 1.7 trillion dollar
Omnibus spending bill and if that
weren't enough the White House visit
from the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zielinski has a really really big news
lots of strong emotions we'll get to
those issues in just a moment
but when big showy political events like
that happen it is always good to look
into which other news stories they are
pushing out of the headlines
and today what do you know
ice has just made a major announcement
that everybody seems to have been too
distracted to notice namely that the
Biden Administration will be releasing
single adult illegal aliens into the
state of Tennessee
the illegal aliens will not be going to
Martha's Vineyard they won't be going to
Rehoboth Beach Delaware they won't be
going to any blue state where Democrats
don't need their votes
they'll be going to Tennessee just like
so many other illegal aliens being
shipped by the Biden Administration into
Republican areas the move is part of the
metapolitical strategy that Democrats
have been pursuing for decades if the
Americans in any particular place don't
like the Democrats policies the
Democrats just need to import new people
who will
there are plenty of sanctuary cities and
Sanctuary States in this country plenty
of blue places that say that they want
more of these illegal immigrants
Democrats could very easily send them
there
but they know that they'll be a bigger
political benefit to the Dems in the red
States if Republicans were serious about
fighting back the state of Tennessee
would organize to arrest these illegal
aliens on the spot when they land
the federal government won't do it but
the state still has police forces the
state has the National Guard if a
Democrat ordered Invasion does not call
for the cops to come arrest people
what does
but Republicans aren't supposed to do
things like that we're not supposed to
even say things like that in fact we're
not even supposed to notice I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Knowles show
me
you know
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Saddle [ __ ]
who says thanks for going over the Pagan
Christmas false reality LOL it might
sound silly but I was one of those
people that believed what she mentioned
I think this is referring to a video I
have by the way it's the woke Christmas
Tick Tock reaction which is on my
YouTube Channel right now so go go check
that out uh it says well I was one of
those people that believed what the
woman in the video mentioned to be true
so fell away from some of the Christmas
traditions not wanting to partake in any
weird Pagan rituals just like I did with
Halloween I think I'll be putting up a
tree next year with a big star on top
I'm so glad to hear that the alleged
pagan origin of Christmas is one of
those things that everybody seems to
know that just isn't true okay as I
explained in the video so go check it
out the woke Christmas tick tocks when
you want to read your Bible
you got to go check at Bible in here
with father Mike Schmitz right now head
on over to ascensionpress.com Knowles if
you are someone who's always wanted to
read and understand the Bible but you're
not sure where to start you've got to
check out the Bible in a year podcast
from Ascension the Bible in a year
podcast is currently the most popular
religion podcast in the United States
millions of people have listened to it
twice it's hit the number one spot on
Apple podcasts
in the Bible and ear podcast father Mike
Schmitz reads the entire Bible in 365
daily episodes providing helpful
commentary reflection and prayer along
the way you might remember those of you
who have been listening to this show for
a long time father Mike Schmitz was one
of our earliest guests on this show and
the Bible linear podcast is pretty much
the only podcast that I will reliably
Listen to I think it is just fantastic
if you want to start reading and more
importantly understanding the Bible this
year go to ascensionpress.com
to download the reading plan for free
that's ascensionpress.com
to download the reading plan for free
who is an American these days I don't
know the Democrats tell us that the
foreign Nationals invading our country
they're all future Americans they're
undocumented Americans but you Americans
you're not Americans
this is according to Stanford University
Stanford University has something called
the elimination of harmful language
initiative
because of course it is a quote
multi-phase multi-year project to
address harmful language in I.T at
Stanford
finally
the guide's purpose is to eliminate many
forms of harmful language and this
includes racist violent and biased
language and by biased language they say
that means disability bias ethnic bias
ethnic slurs gender bias implicit bias
sexual bias
on Stanford's websites wow that's a lot
of biases that's a lot of language
that's a lot of jobs for gender and
ethnic studies Majors who are otherwise
unemployable okay well what are some of
the words they want to get rid of they
want to get rid of the word American
I'm not joking
they say that Americans should not say
that they're American instead Americans
should say that they are U.S citizens
because American
will often refer as only to people from
the United States thereby insinuating
Stanford writes that the U.S is the most
important country in the Americas can
you imagine
can you imagine the gall of some
Americans excuse me U.S citizens to
believe that the United States might be
more important than Bolivia can you
imagine how outrageous is that
to believe that the United States might
be just a little tiny teeny bit more
important than Chile
shocking outrageous
so you can't do it you can't say that
you're American because you're just a
member a citizen of one country and
we've got North America Central America
South America now of course they don't
apply this standard to anybody else
think about the term anti-Semitic
anti-semitic refers to what refers to
Jew hatred
but Semitic doesn't only refer to Jews I
mean now it is taken only to refer to
Jews but Semitic refers to a whole
family of languages including Hebrew
Aramaic Arab Phoenician Acadian other
other languages other peoples
but we don't refer to Arabs as Semitic
if you're anti-semitic it doesn't mean
you hate Arabs right so there you have a
broad term referring to a particular
group of people how about Chinese
when we when we refer to the Chinese
we do not refer to the Taiwanese
but Taiwan the name of Taiwan we call it
Taiwan but it's really called the
Republic of China
but we don't refer we call the Taiwanese
Taiwanese why do the Chinese that's just
one particular albeit a very large and
prominent subset of the Chinese people
why does why does China get to refer to
China
China meaning the the
communist country not the Republic of
China what about those poor Taiwanese we
don't talk about them what about African
Americans we don't refer to Elon Musk as
African-American he is African-American
I mean I refer to him that way because I
think it's funny but most people do not
when we refer to Africans we're only
referring to black people from Africa we
don't refer to boers africaners people
in Zimbabwe formerly Rhodesia or South
Africa we don't refer to the white
people we only refer to the black people
so we use this term there are white
Africans or lots of white Africans
who've been there for many generations
at this point
so all over the world for all sorts of
people we use broad terms to refer to a
particular group but you can't do it for
Americans that's the issue
and and it's true of all the language
policing minister of all of political
correctness and it's true of the whole
leftist game
it's not about broad principles at all
it's not about fairness it's not about
eliminating deceptive or harmful
language it's just about denigrating and
degrading
Americans
First Western Civilization
and specifically Americans or men or
straight people or Christians or it's
all whoever Falls afoul
of the liberal intersectional hierarchy
so especially the worst of the worst
would be a white straight male American
right all the all of that intersects
there
those people are not allowed to be
anything they're not allowed to have any
sort of identity they're they're all
their only identity should be shame and
silence but everybody else doesn't
matter the rules do not apply I think
I'm going to keep calling myself an
American I don't know about you
I think I will do that speaking of
American sovereignty
representative Louis Gomer
has
such a good idea and all the Republicans
should get behind it
representative Louis Gomer who I should
point out is a former judge
says that in the criminal trial of any
individual for the commission of a
criminal offense in the District of
Columbia the individual on trial should
be able to choose the venue for the
proceedings and trial to be in the
district court for the district and
division embracing that individual's
primary residence
let me translate that
into what it's really referring to
January 6th defendants excuse me
January 6th the worst day never in
history defendants
should not be forced to be put on trial
in Washington D.C because the people who
would be on jury in Washington DC are
not really a jury of their peers
Washington DC is a really weird place
okay and these people don't live in
Washington DC the John you were six
people they flew in from all over the
country and what Louis Gomer is saying
is
they're going to be put on trial we're
not saying they're not going to be put
on trial but they should be put on trial
before a jury of their actual peers in
their home districts
I think this is a great idea the
objection to it will be well they
committed their crimes or alleged crimes
or
overblown crimes or trumped up charges
in the District of Columbia therefore
that's where they should be tried okay
that's that's generally a rule of
criminal proceedings except for this
the District of Columbia
is a federal district we forget that now
we pretend that the District of Columbia
is just a regular old blue City where a
lot of people say it should be a state
but it should not be the whole point of
Washington D.C the reason that that's
the nation's capital is because it is
not a state because no State should have
a monopoly over the nation's capital it
is a federal district the Congress has
the right to control basically
everything that happens in the District
of Columbia they have allowed D.C to
have its own mayor they've allowed D.C
to have some local rule
largely a mistake by the way but the
Congress runs DC this is a perfect
opportunity for the Republicans to
justly wield political power when they
take it it'll be stymied in the Senate
it'll be stymied at the White House do
it I want every single Republican to
back this bill this is important not
only to bring some semblance of Justice
to the accused from January 6th but it's
also important
forget about January 6 forget about the
people on trial for a second it's very
important that the Congress reasserts
control over the District of Columbia
which in recent years has just steadily
crept toward becoming the next Blue
State to tilt the balance of power in
this country toward the Democrats and I
don't sleep easy at night when I think
about that in fact the only reason I
have a shot at sleeping is he is because
of Helix sleep right now head on over to
Helix sleep.com Knowles with everything
going on in the world right now you
could use a good night's sleep that is
why you need to check out Helix mattress
I've had my Helix for years now I
absolutely adore it Helix has several
different mattress models to choose from
soft medium and firm mattresses mattress
is great for cooling you down mattresses
for spinal alignment to prevent morning
aches and pains even a helix plus
mattress for plus sized sleepers are you
nervous about buying online you don't
have to be Helix has a sleep quiz that
matches your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you because why would you want to buy a
mattress made for somebody else okay I'm
a married man get out of my mattress get
into your mattress at helixsleep.com
Knowles take their two-minute sleep quiz
find the perfect mattress for your body
and sleep type for a limited time right
now Helix is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners this is their best offer
yet so hurry on over right now to Helix
sleep.com slash Knowles
speaking of Washington DC
major major event yesterday Vladimir
President Vladimir president Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski flew in
from his war zone to meet with Joe Biden
and then to go meet with the members of
Congress
this news had been leaked and then
zielinski and Biden confirmed it
zielinski tweeted out on my way to the
U.S to strengthen resilience and defense
capabilities of Ukraine in particular
the president and I will discuss
cooperation between Ukraine and the U.S
I will also have a speech at the
Congress and a number of bilateral
meetings and then whoever is running
Biden's Twitter account response says I
hope you're having a good flight
Vladimir I'm thrilled to have you here
much to discuss
so this is a stunt it's a pure political
stunt
but it's it's not just a stunt by the
ukrainians trying to get one over on The
Americans
it's not just a stunt by zielinski
trying to squeeze some more money even
more money than he's already gotten out
of the Americans or to drag America into
World War Three as he's been trying to
do for a year now
this is also a stunt by the Democrats
the Democrats are using zelinski just as
much as zielinski is using the Democrats
why is zielinski flying in now this war
has been going on for what 10 months now
11 months almost
he's flying in now
because the Democrats are trying to pass
the Omnibus
and the Omnibus includes 45 billion
dollars for Ukraine
on top of all the money that we've
already given them so zelinski is here
basically on a fundraising trip okay
he's here just to secure that money to
keep buying arms to prolong the war with
Russia
the Democrats are having him come now
because while the Democrats want to get
the 45 billion for Ukraine and they've
all changed their their Twitter names to
include the Ukrainian flag or whatever
the Democrats don't really care all that
much about the Ukraine funding they want
all the other goodies in the 1.7
trillion dollar Omnibus Bill and they
know that if they can Trot out Vladimir
zielinski
who they and the media have turned into
the image of Winston Churchill super
mega wonderful Winston Churchill even
better than the original
then they can pressure the Republicans
to vote for their stupid Omnibus Bill
no different than when Democrats pull
out a cute kid to lobby for gun control
it's it's emotional manipulation it has
very little to do with the actual
realities being debated and discussed
but it's a little trick and so they're
going to do it the question that this
raises though
because it is so clear especially with
with zielinski's groveling visit to get
some more money it is very very clear
that the war is not really between
Ukraine and Russia if the war were just
between Ukraine and Russia it would have
been over after about three days
the war is really between Russia and the
the United States and the U.S led
Coalition of NATO and the European Union
and the entire West that's who the war
is between
Ukraine is a buffer State and has always
been a buffer State and when when
Ukraine was a little too pro-russia the
Americans came in
and tried to pull Ukraine back more
pro-western then after 2014 after the
ride on Revolution Ukraine went more
pro-western Russia said this is
unacceptable that Ukraine is talking
about joining NATO
so Russian invades and it's been this
escalating conflict
with zielinski coming hat in hand saying
give us more money
please Congress please Joe Biden give us
more money it raises this question
do Americans want to control a global
Empire all the way up to Ukraine
that's what it is Vladimir zielinski is
a sort of vassal of the United States
he's he's like a governor the governor
you know when a when a bad storm hits in
Florida or Texas or wherever the the
governors
we'll go up and ask the federal
government for money and then the
federal government usually will give the
money it's the same thing here Solinski
is essentially an imperial Governor out
there in Ukraine he's saying hey us
we're kind of part of your broad Empire
and so we need we need some money
does the U.S want to do that
I don't know that there's an easy answer
on this a lot of people will reactively
say well we're a nation we're not
supposed to have entangling alliances
we're not supposed to have a global
Empire so
let's just get out of everywhere in the
world and just come back to our own
Shores but the fact is we do have a
global Empire we've had a global Empire
for 70 years now
and as as Pericles pointed out in
ancient Athens maybe it wasn't a great
thing
to accumulate the Empire that we have
but we've got it now
okay I think it was miracles we've got
it now and so it'd be very dangerous to
give up the Empire that we already have
that's the question that Americans are
debating right now
but it it goes back to those magic
tricks okay the surface level story
Ukrainian Independence and we need to
stand up for the community of Nations
and that what it's it's an Imperial War
it's a war between two empires the Great
American Empire and a formerly great
Empire Russia which is trying to rebuild
its Empire
that's what the war is about do we want
to be involved in that war
do we want to do we want to vote for
this Omnibus Bill the Omnibus includes
so much terrible stuff the Omnibus I
went through a lot of what the Omnibus
includes yesterday forgot to mention it
includes 286 million dollars in title 10
funding
for voluntary Family Planning projects
money that will go toward
abortion bills that's what that means
voluntary Family Planning projects means
abortion so that's going to include a
lot of money for Planned Parenthood
the super radical pro-abortion groups
are Furious about this
because it's roughly the same amount of
money that we give these people every
single year but they say well in the
wake of the Dobbs decision now that Roe
v Wade has been overruled you need to
give us way more money because abortion
is way more under threat
my reaction would be quite the opposite
Republicans in recent years have gone
along with this kind of abortion funding
because a lot of them are squishes and
because a lot of them aren't
particularly principled but the excuse
that they gave was look we live in
America with Roe v Wade you're not gonna
really do all that much about abortion
as long as Roe v Wade is up in books and
so we give them a few hundred million
dollars no big deal
but we are not living in Roe v Wade
America right now we are living in
post-row America
we are living in Dobbs America
we do not have to fund abortion there is
no federally recognized right to
abortion that is gone lump that away
with the Easter Bunny
if there was any argument to give
hundreds of millions of dollars to
Planned Parenthood
it was that there was a federal right to
an abortion that's over we don't need to
give these people any money zero dollars
and furthermore Republicans do not have
to vote for this bill the Democrats have
tried to back Republicans into a corner
where they feel like they have to vote
for this Omnibus Bill
if the Republicans don't vote for the
Omnibus Bill then the government will
shut down
okay who cares the government shut down
plenty of times we're about to retake
the house that's why the Democrats and
the Swiss Republicans are trying to Ram
this thing through before the
Republicans retake the house because if
they can get this funding package
through
then there's nothing for the House
Republicans to do they'll they'll hold
some investigations they'll hold some
hearings and yell at some people but
they won't actually do anything because
the the Congress doesn't really pass
individual bills anymore they just every
so often pass one of these massive
multi-trillion dollar Omnibus packages
so once they take care of that with the
Dem still in charge of both houses of
Congress and the white house then it's
over
and then there's nothing left for the
House Republicans to do BS
I can get a little salty with my
language I'm going to try to I'm going
to try to Reign it in and be very mature
and responsible and diplomatic about
this and say Republicans
you don't have to vote for it you can if
you don't want the government to shut
down you can pass a short-term spending
package that will get you through
January or even February
then hash this thing out for real
it is absolutely absurd that the
Congress was given three days to read a
4200 page bill
let alone debate and and then vote on it
no way
do not vote for this thing guys any
Republican who votes for this 1.7
trillion dollar omnibus
is willfully surrendering to Democrats
speaking of Wills you need to go get a
will you got to check out epic will
right now go to epicwell.com use promo
code Knowles you need to have a will I
had not redone my will in a very very
long time mercifully it has just been
completed because without a will you
have no idea what's going to happen to
your financial assets and your personal
property and your end of life decisions
and most importantly your kids who is
going to raise your children should you
and your spouse die before they are of
age without a will the state is going to
make this decision for you if you're
just starting out and you don't have
thousands of dollars to spend on an
attorney but you want to make sure that
your savings your belongings and your
family are all protected you've got to
create your will at epicwill.com today
epic will bundles your last will living
will Healthcare power of attorney HIPAA
release and durable Financial power of
attorney it only costs 119 bucks for a
single person to create a will when you
use promo code nulls you will save 10
percent go to epicwill.com use promo
code Knowles kwles to save 10 on Epic
Will's complete will package that is
epic will.com promo code Knowles
Republicans don't need to vote for these
things that the Democrats are ramming
down our throat increasingly the people
are on our side when it comes to the
issues and people that you might not
always expect we talk about Joe Rogan
Bill Maher Tulsi gabber these Democrats
Elon Musk Democrats who've come over and
and cited more with the conservatives
recently
goes way further than that Tim Robbins
one of the biggest lib actors in one of
the biggest industries obviously in
Hollywood he just came out and he
admitted to Russell Brand that the covid
lockdowns
changed his mind
we went into lockdown with healthy
people with children and that didn't
seem to be wise to me so
um I'm not a scientist I'm not a doctor
I don't know the intricacies of of uh
data on this all I can respond to is as
some someone that has is concerned about
what the result of those
doctrines that policy had on us as human
beings and it's not good we turned into
um tribal
angry vengeful people
and I I don't think that's something
that is sustainable for the Earth that
we
start demonizing people that don't agree
with our
particular Health policies and turn them
into monsters
look I'm not a scientist look I don't I
didn't I didn't know but
this wasn't good
that is the opinion
of a lot of liberals
who initially bought into all the covet
hysteria and Dr fauci and lockdown and
six feet apart and wear the hanky on
your face and Trust the science they
started out seriously believe me some of
us didn't start out believing that okay
some of us I don't want to name any
names here okay I don't want to toot my
own horn some of us understood what
kovid was from the very beginning
some of us when they tried to lock us
down and actually forced us to lock down
in California some of us were back in
the office within 36 hours because some
of us called up Jeremy boring and said
Jeremy I'm not doing this this is all
ridiculous I'm showing up to work
tomorrow and he said okay I understood
I'm already at the office
okay so I'm not saying who would have
done such a thing it was me it was me so
some of us knew it and I'm sure many of
you knew that from the beginning as well
but there were a lot of liberals who
very earnestly believed
the science and the lab coats and the
masks and the fauci
and then realized wait a second
are we the Baddies
they had that reaction he said wait or
the thing that we all clamored for we
huh maybe those crazy right-wing
fanatical Republican extremists Maybe
maybe they were onto something
covid-19 is being called
the great reset
not just by tinfoil hat people but by
very very powerful Elites
the head of the world economic forum
his various Associates
Yuval Harari one of the philosophers
behind the great resentment World
economic Forum Bill Gates
world leaders you you see this with King
Charles of England you see this with
lots of other political leaders they're
saying covid-19 is the opportunity to
reset our economy and our food
production and our political order and
our technology and our and what is the
great reset always amount to
and amounts to eat the bugs live in the
pods give up your rights own nothing and
be happy
surveillance everywhere
no political sovereignty
it's a it's a reset of our very Humanity
that's what they want it to be
and that's insane and terrible and we
should fight a tooth and nail
but covid-19 provides another
opportunity for another great reset
covid-19 provides an opportunity to
reset political alliances I don't think
that I am being overly optimistic here
or hyperbolic there are lots of people
who got very red pilled during covid
during the lockdowns
a lot of people who trusted the entire
liberal establishment for their whole
freaking Lives who said wait they lied
to me about this they lied to me in such
an egregious way what else have they
been lying about
and this is the moment for republicans
and conservatives and just normal people
to capitalize on that and say yeah come
on in come on in Tim Robbins the water
is warm
this is this is not just your 1980s
battle
between the left and the right and the
Democrats and the Republicans
politics means applying Eternal
principles to changing circumstances and
that means that political alliances will
change over time and one of the problems
with the squishes where they really air
and I think they air earnestly and
unwittingly and sincerely but they find
a lot of comfort in play acting the
political battles of the 1980s they use
all the language of the 1960s through
the 1980s the period that they consider
to be the Halcyon Days of the
conservative movement the days of
William F Buckley Jr and Ronald Reagan
and so they'll use these terms they'll
say we've got to fight the collectivists
we need free markets for the smallest
minority of all the individual and we
use all these cute lines that they heard
in reruns from Milton Friedman and Bill
Buckley and all the rest of them
and they pretend that they're still
fighting Soviet communism as an
international conspiracy the
conspiracies have changed the Soviet
Union doesn't exist anymore the threats
are different okay so I'm not saying
that we need to Chuck out all the things
we learned during that movement but we
have to have the guts and the the
political Vision to fight the battles
that are actually happening right now in
one of those battles the probably the
biggest battle
is not between left and right and
Republican and Democrat and all the rest
of it
it's between the secular globalists
and the traditional
nationalists
the conservatives the people who like
their communities
that Donald Trump pointed this out
he said the Battle of our age is between
globalism and nationalism
and by globalism we're not talking about
the Catholic Empire of the Middle Ages
we're talking about
in the world economic Forum in the U.N
peddling abortion and contraception and
weird bugs and mass migration and
destroying our economies and all the all
the terrible stuff that you have seen
that the libs have used covid-19 to
promote
that's what it's about and so this is
our opportunity are we going to welcome
in the Tim Robbins are we going to win
them over or not are we going to keep
play acting the battles from the 1980s
people are moving over to our side Chris
Cuomo is moving over to our side okay
Chris Cuomo
a member of the Cuomo family
the number one Democrat family in the
state of New York
Chris Cuomo who for years now has played
this far left lib on CNN he gets canned
from CNN he goes over to the news
channel news nation and he's clearly
pivoting to the center actually
just the other day I was invited on
Chris Cuomo's show
and I said that I would go on the show I
or you know I tried to make the timing
work but I said that I was at least
interested and for whatever reason the
appearance didn't happen I don't know
maybe got spiked by a senior producer or
something like that the very fact that
they reached out
shows you though I said gosh I
I assume I'm too much of an authentic
conservative
for Chris Cuomo to have on the show you
know I usually Chris Cuomo just has CNN
conservatives by which I mean liberal
Democrats and he never has actual
conservatives on the show wow that must
mean that they're pivoting strategy and
then I looked at the segment that Chris
Cuomo aired on news Nation I was very
very impressed it was a segment
about D transitioners
d-transitioner is not who you are and
what you are that is the role that
you're playing in this story
um and that's where it ends in terms of
people understanding your situation
do you believe that your
predicament of deciding whether or not
transitioning was right for you was
about the process that got you into it
or was it that you had a change after
transition
um I think it really came from the fact
that I since I transitioned so young I
just kind of I grew up and I matured a
bit more
and I really like thought about my
future in ways that I was just not
capable of at the time
of like the medical interventions like I
thought about like do I want biological
children and I kind of had like an oh
shoot moment because I realized what
could have been done
there and that I could have really
damaged that chance along with just like
like I said really just getting older
and growing up a little bit more and
being able to actually process what
these feelings were
it's a fabulous interview and Chris
Cuomo became the first as far as I can
tell the first person to host a
detransition panel on television news
that's very impressive
why is he doing it I don't I don't mean
to question his motives or maybe he's
really moving to the right
could be
getting canned by CNN probably would do
that to a person so maybe it's totally
sincere but at the very least
Chris Cuomo is a very sharp political
actor the cuomos are very very sharp
political people
and Chris Cuomo I'm sure is seeing wow
this crazy transgender stuff this does
not play in Peoria
all right this is a minority minority
opinion in America that a man can really
become a woman and a woman can really
become a man and we should pump 16 year
old girls full of hormones and and
potentially sterilize them and destroy
their voice forever and this is not good
stuff okay
and it makes for a much more interesting
TV by the way this is much more
interesting than just whatever stupid
talking points CNN sends down at the top
of the day you've got to talk about
Russia you know talk about how the walls
are closing in for the 10 millionth time
yeah talk about how Trump
paid his taxes or whatever yeah that's
good no this is obviously much much more
interesting and it's much more
interesting when people can think a
little bit more independently
it's a line I always quote Dante quote
Dante all the time but when Dante's
seeing his ancestor in Paradise
kachiguida kachiguita gives him some
political advice he gives him two pieces
of political advice and actually the
first one relates to the top of the show
he says uh that letting in too many
immigrants ruin cities
saying this from Heaven okay but the
second thing he says is you can't just
tie yourself entirely to a political
party and make that your whole identity
you're going to get totally burned okay
ultimately you need to transcend those
petty little squalls and become a party
unto yourself
and that's true for all of us and you
are seeing that happen especially on the
left right now so what does that mean
when these people are waking up and
thinking in a little bit more of an
independent way we can win them over we
don't need to Cave to the libs we don't
need to feel pressured to vote for their
stupid 1.7 trillion dollar spending bill
that everybody hates come on
conservatives grow a spine I know that
conservatives have a spine come on
Congressional Republicans grow a spine
the things that you want to do generally
speaking are the right things to do and
on top of it they're political winners
because the people are on your side
it amuses me
people use that phrase educate yourself
as a retort because the people who use
that phrase are ironically usually among
the least educated people out there
they are the ones who need the education
they would do well to tune into Ben
Shapiro's book club which is back
tonight at 8 7 Central exclusively on
daily wear plus this month's book is the
screwtable letters by C.S Lewis tune in
to hear Ben discuss the novel and share
his notes with you you must be an
all-access member to join in on the fun
head on over to dailywire.com Knowles to
become a member and join bench press
book club tonight eight seven Central
dailywire.com Knowles today
speaking of opinions changing over time
great news out of a court uh Court this
is the fifth Circuit Court of Appeals
has just ruled that the Biden
Administration cannot enforce its covid
vaccine mandate on federal contractors
this according to a ruling on Monday
it was a two to one decision so again
those judges matter you know it wasn't
an unanimous decision but the fifth
circuit says
that another vaccine mandate pushed by
the federal government
is not legit cannot happen
really good news you remember the first
one of these vaccine mandates that got
struck down was the private sector
mandate and the daily wire LED the
lawsuit we were the first company to
bring the suit against the federal
government we won in the Supreme Court
but
Federal contractors first First
Responders or health care workers rather
federal employees the list goes on they
all still had to take the fauci ouchy
and now slowly we're seeing those
crumble as well
which is a good moral victory
but it's not a political victory
it's not it's not a real political
Victory because
the federal contractors already took the
shot or they lost their jobs
the libs knew that a lot of this would
be rendered unconstitutional
the Liberals knew this when they passed
their mandates and all their crazy
emergency measures they knew it okay but
what they also knew was by the time that
these things were struck down by the
courts it wouldn't matter
they knew that by the time they were
struck down by the courts they would
have already gotten what they wanted it
reminds me of
an historical example that I keep coming
back to
the 1948 Senate race in Texas LBJ is
running LBJ cheats he stuffs ballot
boxes he barely wins with enough votes
everyone knew that the race was stolen
the the race litigation goes all the way
up to the Supreme Court the Supreme
Court finally says look we don't have
jurisdiction here we don't want to hear
about it you've sort out your own
election sound familiar by the way does
that sound like any elections we've had
recently
so LBJ enters into the Senate
then JFK picks LBJ to be his vice
president then JFK is assassinated
potentially by the CIA I'm not making
that claim but I did see this week there
were certain documents released about
the JFK assassination that hadn't been
released before and they suggested that
at the very least the CIA had some kind
of relationship with Lee Harvey Oswald
and anyway the whole thing is it's a
it's a topic for another time but anyway
JFK gets assassinated then LBJ becomes
the president LBJ passes the Great
Society
terrible legislation ramps up the war in
Vietnam just awful stuff
he leaves office
he dies
and in the 1990s his biographer Robert
Carro shows that he stole the 1948
senate race
what a great moral victory
doesn't matter
he already had his whole career he
already got exactly what he wanted
Republicans conservatives
are very good
at being proven right later on
totally I mean we were proven right
about the vaccines
vaccines not not anywhere near as safe
and effective as we were told they were
we were proven right about the masks we
were proven right about the six feet
social distancing the public health
officials eventually admitted they
plucked that out of thin air we were
right about the origin of the Wuhan
virus we were right about U.S funding of
the origin of the Wuhan virus we were
and that's just one issue
that's just one issue among a zillion
we've been proven right about pretty
much everything
after the fact
it would be much better rather than
losing a political battle and then being
proven right later it would be much
better to win
okay
so we've got to keep fighting now give
me another example on Election fraud
2020 election fraud lawsuit in Fulton
County
has just gotten some new life
2020. we're now approaching 2023 we're
still fighting over 2020.
and the labs and the squishes don't want
us to keep fighting over 2020 but some
conservatives are keeping it alive this
was a case that was initially dismissed
by a judge in October of 2021 it has
been working its way through the court
system now it's being sent back to the
appeals court
thanks to an order from the Georgia
Supreme Court
about ballot fraud and absentee ballots
in 2020.
Central to this case is the issue of
standing you're only allowed to bring a
suit if you have standing if you can if
you can prove that you have some
particular injury as a result of some
issue and so a lot of the cases over
election fraud have flopped because the
court will say well you don't have any
standing there's no reason for us even
to hear the case out this one continues
to go through
and I strongly suspect that it is going
to find evidence or at the very least
strong evidence will be presented of
fraud in Georgia
of all the states where alleged fraud
occurred Georgia looked like one of the
worst in 2020.
great I hope we win I hope we prove that
the 2020 election was completely stolen
by the Democrats that would be a great
moral Victory but it won't matter
because the big issue here is not being
proven right the big issue is time
we might be proven correct but to what
effect
we need to win
it would be far better
than litigating all of this out years
after the elections it would be far
better for republicans
to to change the laws back get rid of
early voting get rid of all these
absentee ballots
reinstitute voter ID
and then get into some ballot harvesting
ourselves and then be proactive and
start using the same kind of machine
techniques that the Democrats are using
that would be a much better strategy so
that we actually win the elections on
the night of rather than litigating this
thing out for years and then maybe
getting the moral Victory oh yeah look
it actually turns out you were right
guys
hey you're totally right they stole
Georgia
anyway never mind
going back to my pod now to eat the bugs
because the Democrats have been winning
for years uh based on all of this sort
of shenanigans and you can't do anything
about it not great
the Democrats are really really smart
about this issue of time
Democrats in 2022 Took a ton of money
from Sam bankman freed Sam bankman freed
was the head of FTX this was probably
the biggest Financial scam in American
history that just collapsed
all these Democrats Took a ton of money
Sam bagman freed contributed roughly 39
million dollars to Democrat nominees
during the 2022 midterms according to
data from open Secrets so the Democrats
have just announced
they are going to give some of the money
back
the Senate majority pack
which exists to elect Democrats
announced that it will return
three million dollars
wow that's
what about the other 36
what about the other
18 times that amount of money that the
Democrats also took are you going to
return that guys
no
no this one Democrat pack is going to
return a relatively small amount of
money
but the rest of it no big deal
three million dollars a drop in the
bucket compared to what was going on
they're very good about this
they're very smart when it comes to time
and they're going to run out the clock
and then eventually maybe they'll say
okay we'll give a little bit more money
back it doesn't matter they already got
all their money they already won the
election
doesn't matter now speaking of
disparities in money
Oprah Winfrey is under a ton of fire
right now
she was asked she was walking out of
some event to give a recommendation for
a Christmas gift here's what she said
favorite gift for my mom she's not doing
well
you know a wonderful thing is that
jewelry box that's at um moose that I
had on favorite things a beautiful red
jewelry box with a little that's too
expensive for me it's really not it's
like a hundred and some dollars a little
low in my price budget that's more than
a hundred dollars it's my mom she's she
understands she has sentimental gifts
the perfect gift for your mom
the reasons why you love her and you
make a beautiful card and it's your top
ten yeah that's that's perfect and they
said to Metro right and it's sentimental
you're tattooed Oprah is being attacked
for this because she said well it's only
a hundred dollars you know it's a little
bit out of my price range 100 what are
you super poor or something like that
can't afford a hundred dollar gift
what's wrong with you and so people are
attacking her for this
there are so many reasons to attack
Oprah
Oprah herself might be a sign of the
Apocalypse like Oprah is
has done so much damage to the spiritual
state of Americans
and people all over the world peddling
her new age gobbledygook just liberal
awful malenthusian terrible I I could go
on and on and on about all the Terrible
Things Oprah's done
I thought that was fine
she Oprah is a billionaire and she gave
you a recommendation for something that
costs like a hundred dollars
which most people can't afford if it's
going to be their main Christmas gift
for their mother there are some people
who can't afford it and especially now
it's tough Financial Times and inflation
is very bad so I'm not yes that's true
but and then she immediately gave a
great response
he said okay well if you can't afford
that just write around a list of the top
10 reasons why you love her so much
that would be a very meaningful gift
very sentimental probably more so than
the jewelry box that was I thought that
was a good answer
okay maybe it's just the spirit of the
Season I'm feeling very charitable I've
got to even say nice things about
Oprah now speaking of
Christmas
speaking of
all sorts of misinformation going around
uh I mentioned at the top of the show
there's this Tick Tock of uh woke
Christmas facts I debunk it it's going
wild on my Channel right now so you can
find it over on the YouTube channel well
anyway the gal who I was reacting to
she's she's out with more
more facts more facts that happen not to
be correct as Ronald Reagan said the
problem with our liberal friends is not
that they're ignorant they just know so
much that isn't so so that we will be
getting into it right now the rest of
the show continues now you don't want to
miss it if you're not a member click the
link in the description and join us
[Music]
[Music]